what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting into I guess another
episode of too powerful for Marvel
movies and this one I want to talk about
Darwin he's so unique in in Marvel
Comics like there really isn't anybody
like you I mean like there's there's
well there's character similar to him
but but you guys'll see in due time so
really I mean Darwin's been around for I
mean no super long amount of time he
showed up in 2006 so he's been around
for like 12 years of the time that were
recording this video but for the most
part what makes Darwin's so interesting
is the fact that he can instantaneously
adapt to any circumstance so the way
this played out was in a story called
x-men deadly Genesis and in this story
what we ended up finding out is that in
Marvel Comics back in the day the way
the story was originally written with a
giant-size x-men number one is you had a
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby's original x-men
so like Cyclops and beast and Iceman and
Jean and an angel and somewhere along
the line they had all been sent on a
mission to locate what was basically an
energy signature that belong to a mutant
but when they arrived there they
realized it was a mutant island that was
called krakoa and what ended up
happening here is this mutant island had
basically become sentient
and it had like captured all the x-men
like the original x-men now Cyclops
showed back up at the Xavier Institute
and we end up finding out later on that
Cyclops was operating under the control
of kokoa and was sent forward to bring
back more x-men and so when Cyclops gets
to the Xavier Institute he basically
panics and tells Xavier like the xmitter
are have been defeated and and like I
think they're dead like I'm not even a
hundred percent sure I barely made it
out with my life and so what Xavier does
is he goes to a woman named war
McTaggart now more McTaggart was a
mutant geneticist who was like in a lot
of ways like a very very close friend
and even like a one-time lover of
Charles Xavier and she was actually the
person who kind of housed mutants who
didn't really have a place in the Xavier
Institute or she served as kind of a
Waystation which is to say those mutants
who were looking to travel to the Xavier
Institute where their powers weren't
quite under control enough to be able to
be safe in the Xavier Institute proper
she would take them under her wing and
then she would teach them how to use
their powers to a degree and then she
would hand in to Xavier who would give
them proper training but the idea behind
this was that darwin was one of a
handful of mutants who had been who had
been you know operating under the the
guidance of a more McTaggart now this
would this was alongside like Vulcan the
third Summers brother who's super
powerful he's like he's like I mean I
consider him to be like a beyond
omega-level mutant but most people just
say omega-level along
with uh Petra in SWANCC but what ended
up happening here is because Xavier
needed a new team in order to rescue the
original team secretly he took these
mutants from Mora mckagan I mean she
kind of handed him over but he took them
and put them through basically like
speed training it like like rushed him
through the training process and then
sent them on their mission and the idea
was that they they were basically just
not capable of being able to handle a
conflict on that scale that defeated the
original x-men because they just weren't
ready but in Charles Xavier mind like
they like there was no choice there was
no alternative they had to be rescued as
soon as possible and this was the
closest thing he had to like a new team
now of course that kind of begs the
question why did he just contact the
Avengers or like any of the other
superhero teams that were out there the
Fantastic Four well because the story
didn't call for it and so the result is
that is that Charles Xavier sent them
out and then they all basically perished
they all basically died the only ones
who didn't die were Darwin and Vulcan
and what Darwin had actually done was
kind of convert himself or kind of merge
himself with Vulcan and then like
preserve Vulcan that way and that's how
it is it Gabriel Summers comes back
during the events of x-men deadly
Genesis in 2006 when he wakes up after
the events of House of M but when it
comes to voloom sword when it comes to
Darwin he has instantaneous adaptation
and so this is what's called a passive
power and we've talked about this before
in Marvel Comics you have active powers
and you have passive powers active
powers or powers that a person has to
like activate on their own so like
really good example of an active power
is like when Cyclops shoots his energy
blast right like he has to open his eyes
and then the beams pass through his eyes
or something like that or even somebody
like um like Trevor Fitzroy that's a
really good example Trevor Fitzroy who
creates portals through time so when you
really talk about that is a power that
they have to actually activate and use a
passive power is a power that's always
active so like Wolverines healing factor
or like Deadpool's healing factor that
power is always activating and it's
always working you know this just
happens to be that we only really see it
when they sustain some kind of injury or
something like that but that's why
Wolverine has it has like a very slow
aging process is because the the healing
factor is constantly healing his body
now like a like an arm hitting it you
know like like like you holding a hammer
and hitting something eventually the
healing factor will wear out but the
idea is it'll take a long long time
potentially thousands if not tens of
thousands of years to happen we don't
really know because what we ran had
adamantium bonded to his body so they
kind of sped up the amount of time at
which hate for his healing factor to
burn out because it's constantly
fighting off adamantium poisoning and
then also the various forms of damage
that he receives but with Darwin like
that's a passive power he
to automatically adapt to anything and
so if you if you throw Darwin in space
he'll adapt and have the ability to
breathe in space if you put it with
water
he'll automatically adapt and he'll be
able to breathe water and so when you
take a character like that and you put
them against the Avengers then Darwin
would easily be able to destroy them the
only way to really I mean the only way
to really be able to get past that is if
you had a character that could move fast
enough that they could somehow overcome
that speed at which his body adapts but
it doesn't work that way because his
body's almost like his body's covered
with like thousands of eyes or something
like that some of those lines it's since
is what kind of power a person has in an
intern automatically adapts to it right
I mean it's the only way that power
could work you know if Darwin had to
physically see a person's power in order
to adapt to it then it would kind of
take away from that it wouldn't be
instant you know instantaneous
adaptation and so if you if you take
Darwin and you drop them into the
Avengers universe and then you say okay
like we are going to have him face up
against the Incredible Hulk his body
would automatically adapt to be able to
withstand the might of the Incredible
Hulk now that begs the question is there
a limit to it if the Incredible Hulk
strength is limitless will Darwin adapt
to basically be able to withstand the
limitless straight to the Incredible
Hulk someone like Thor does not have
unlimited strength he's just exceedingly
strong so if you were to find Thor his
body would adapt to being able to
overcome the the strengths or at least
deal accept the damage that Thor deals
in his various you know where this was
strength oh if you're talking about like
Captain America well that's pretty easy
because he could just run really fast
and punch hard when it comes to the
Scarlet Witch you know that's that's
that's see to me that's an interesting
scenario because a Scarlet Witch in in
the Marla Cinematic Universe is not like
Marvel Comics trying to model comics
it's basically luck manipulation is it's
kind of manipulating reality in a
localized space this is how it was
originally she could kind of create
these hexes so that should give you sort
of been luck in her favor and it worked
for what it was things were just kind of
happened to work out for her but in the
MCU The Scarlet Witch is more akin to
like Jean Grey from the x-men which kind
of begs the question what are they gonna
do when Jean Grey from the x-men gets
rolled in they're gonna be like hey
you're just like me oh we should change
that and now you can do all kinds of
crazy reality warping stuff but but with
somebody like like telepathy or
telekinesis like the mind in the body of
Darwin will adapt to overcome that so if
you have Darwin who's running around out
there and somebody runs up on him with
telepathy his mind will adapt to
basically become immune to telepathy
you know telekinesis the whole nine
yards I mean it gets kind of crazy when
it when it comes to a character with
that level of power and that's why for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe he would
just be too powerful because he's
basically a one-man army
now again it's adaptation which is which
is to say in relation to his own
physical body and so if you know for
Darwin he can't believe it can't really
adopt like adapt to use like energy
blasts right it's more of just like the
physical structure of his body that's
being changed I mean there were times I
marvel comic's when he would turn his
hands and like rocks and there were
times when he even became proactive
whereas it was normally a defense
mechanism that would just kind of kick
in they could actually shift things up
on his own I mean that was a short-lived
thing you know after a battle that he
had with Helen but but the fact remains
that he can't really create like energy
blast so he can't really go on the
offensive he's more of like a defensive
character but still I mean even then in
his own right it's still exceedingly
powerful because at that point all it
would take is for like The Incredible
Hulk to run up on him and then Darwin
basically adapts the ability to either
counter the Incredible Hulk strength or
match the Incredible Hulk strength
meaning he becomes as strong as the
Incredible Hulk and then in turn just
like goes on a warpath against the
Avengers I mean again because it's a
defensive mechanism it's not one of
those things that he can turn off right
it's not like okay now that I've
defeated the Incredible Hulk like I'm
going to shut this whole thing down it
has a mind of its own and it works on
its own so again I guess it gets kind of
wild there I mean it gets really really
crazy and that's why I say he's so
unique I mean he's not as unique as
likely to write like Meech can shut down
the powers of people of anybody with any
measure of power because he affects the
brain stem the actual nervous system so
someone like vanos who ran up on leech
like he could likely could literally
shut down the powers of Fano somebody
like Wolverine or even like mr. M who
was like a reality warper leech shut
down his ability to work reality by just
being in his general vicinity it's only
got a radius of about ten feet but even
then I would say because because leech
has that power if it were able to be
expanded to whatever range leech wanted
to be then he would become like probably
the single most powerful character
because the best best offense is a good
defense but the fact remains you know
when it comes to Darwin what makes him
so powerful is the fact that he can
adapt to any situation and his body will
change to become whatever he needs to be
in order to overcome a particular
scenario so again you know super
strength super speed agility becoming
like bulletproof or fireproof or things
like that that's the kind of stuff you
can pull off it's pretty wild when you
get down to it but it's also pretty
interesting so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
[Music]